almost every all-time great comedian
over the last 50 years has made their
way through the comedy store to see
guidance from Mitzi and the insane
amount of exposure Seinfeld brought to
stand up along with all the current
comedians who were inspired by the show
makes Jerry's offstage influence almost
immeasurable
what the reason for this rivalry has
been largely debated for years now but
according to some of the comedians who
knew Mitzi best her rejection of
Seinfeld most likely boiled down to one
of two different reasons the first
theory is that Jerry Seinfeld was
already too far along in his comedy
career for mitzi's liking as she
preferred to work with newer comedians
who weren't quite as polished Jerry was
asked about his relationship with Mitzi
in a recent interview where he said
quote Mitzi Shore was a great motivator
of mine she disliked me instantly
because I was very independent and
that's not the comedy store model this
is 1980. you need to be a wounded broken
Winged Bird or you're not funny